so how do just to linger on these
packages numpy Pi torch tensorflow yeah
how do they play nicely together so is
uh Mojo just supposed to be let's talk
about the machine learning ones
is Mojo kind of vision to replace pie
torture tensorflow uh to incorporate it
what's what's the relationship in this
all right so um dance so take a step
back so I wear many hats so you're
you're angling it on the Mojo side yes
Mojo is a programming language and so it
can help solve the C C plus plus python
Feud that's happening the fire Emoji got
me I'm sorry we should be talking
modular yes yes yes okay so the fire
Emoji is amazing I love it uh it's it's
a big deal the other side of this is the
fire Emoji is in service of solving some
big AI problems yes right and so the big
AI problems are again this fragmentation
this Hardware nightmare this uh this
explosion of new potential but that's
not getting felt by the industry right
and so when you look at how does the
modular engine help tensorflow and Pie
torch right it's not replacing them
right in fact when I talk to other
people again they don't like to rewrite
all their code you have people that are
using a bunch of high torch a bunch of
tensorflow they have models that they've
been building over the course of many
years right and when I talk to them
there's a few exceptions but generally
they don't want to rewrite all their
code
right and so what we're doing is we're
saying okay well you don't have to
rewrite all your code what happens is
the modular engine goes in there and
goes underneath tensorflow and pytorch
it's fully compatible and just provides
better performance better predictability
better tooling
it's a better experience that helps lift
tensorflow and pytorch and make them
even better I love python I love
tensorflow I love by torch right this is
about making the world better because we
need AI to go further but if I have a
process that trains a model and they
have a process that performs inference
on that model and have the model itself
what should I do with that in the long
Arc of History
in terms of if I use pytorch to train it
should I rewrite stuff in Mojo would
that if I care about performance oh so I
mean again it depends so if you care
about performance then writing and Mojo
is going to be way better than writing
in Python but if you look at
um if you look at llm companies for
example so you look at open AI rumored
and you look at many of the other folks
that are working on maybe these many of
these LMS and other like Innovative
machine learning models on the one hand
they're innovating in the data
collection and the model billions of
parameters in the model architecture and
the RL HF and the the like all the all
the cool things that people are talking
about but on the other hand they're
spending a lot of time writing Cuda
girls
so you say wait a second how much faster
could all this progress go if they were
not having to handwrite all these Cuda
kernels right and so there are a few
technologies that are out there and
people have been working on this problem
for a while and
um and they're trying to solve subsets
of the problem again kind of fragmenting
the space and so what Mojo provides for
these kinds of companies is the ability
to say cool I can have a unifying Theory
right again this the The Better Together
the unifying Theory the the two world
problem or the three world problem or
the end world problem like this is the
thing that is slowing people down and so
as we help solve this problem I think
it'll be very helpful for making this
whole cycle go faster